for the past week the phone's been
ringing off the hook here at the surreal
residence and all stuck in North and
Germany
the caller's all want to talk to 14 year
old Reem she became an international
sensation after an exchange with
Chancellor Angela Merkel on live TV
that's we divvy that when I watched the
video I feel like I should have phrased
the whole thing a bit differently that
maybe I left something out I guess had
dreams family are asylum seekers from
Palestine they've been in Germany for
four years but they could still face
deportation here's what Reem said to
Merkel as long as I don't know if I can
stay here I don't know what my future
will look like
doesn't my politics is sometimes hard in
Palestinian refugee camps in Lebanon
there are thousands upon thousands of
people if we now say you can all come
well we just can't Merkel then told Reem
not speeding up the asylum process is a
priority but she was already bursting
into tears the incident quickly went
viral with critics called in Chancellor
heartless the few hando many viewers
obviously got a different impression she
really showed a lot of compassion and I
left happier because she gave me hope
and strength Hafner and stacker he gave
mad today the stock wheels call this
low-income housing complex home they
moved here in 2013 after spending two
years in a refugee center Reem was born
in Baalbek some 80 kilometers northeast
of Beirut she's been suffering since she
was born with injuries to her head her
legs and one eye
in 2011 the family came to Germany to
give dreamed the chance of undergoing
expensive stem-cell therapy when it
became clear that the treatment wasn't
working the sub wheels fled to Sweden so
they wouldn't be forced to return to
Lebanon but Swedish authorities did
deport them back to Germany today Reem
feels completely at home here
she and her brother Hamid go to school
have made many friends it's very well to
touch out of it would be a total shame
if I had to leave this place for good
I'd have to start all over again all of
my plans for the future everything I've
built here will be gone dancin to come
suddenly here off football top and then
Beck hmm hurrah Madrid Girona it would
be terrible if they sent us back the
girls would have it so bad because the
medical situation in the Palestinian
refugee camps is really awful Doha
declaw door and mozzie Marla Danny Green
wants to stay in hostel and become an
English teacher legislation introduced
recently could make that dream possible
it gab Young's migrants who've
assimilated to life in Germany a right
to remain there that provides a safety
net of swords for children like green
but the uncertainty is still a burden
for them to bear
you